the nopon's is going to introduce us to
the Jupiter notebooks running in a
docker swarm cloud thank you okay thank
you okay can you hear me yes perfect
so welcome everybody thanks to be here
now with that i'm jordi i'm working in a
research group that is in the IRB
barcelona genomic lab we work with
genomic data and this is why I have put
this here because it's the only relation
with the talk that I have put this DNA
double Alec here but the rest of the dog
has no nothing related with genomics it
just I will explain our set up and not
only this you will see but that we are
using in in our research group that is a
group of where 16 but using the cluster
12 person just to survive so ok ok three
o'clock
I'd Saturday at least for me is my
siesta and coffee time heavy one hat I
didn't have a time for coffee but so
import a bit of coffee just for all of
you on let's start
okay so first what is a loudly stop it's
a first because you will see that at
some point is like a workaround solution
the thing that we have been done that we
are using so then to make this more
useful for you the dock but even if it
recorded in one year maybe the solution
is it's useless I will try to introduce
a video conductor of the Jupiter and to
give you an overview of different
solutions and more or less when we want
to run not be remotely in a cluster what
we can do so this that the first two
points then I will explain a bit very
quickly the Jupiter half how it works
and then our alternative solution that
we are using to avoid one problem that
we explain and there's the pros and cons
and and at the end I would like to to
thing I will give my ideas now the thing
that I will like in a future to
implement in our solution or or in
general the Jupiter that I will like
that it will have or or some combination
with okay you will see just just two and
then it will be also nice if some of you
want to add something in this future
view at the end or whatever so so let's
start first them this is the main the
main components so we have the kernel
the ipython kernel now that it comes
from the ipython console note but now
it's like an interface so as you may
know that we have several
implementations with several languages
but the kernel itself it's it is
interface that it's quite simple this is
why it makes this interface very
powerful now that induce a message is 0
I am QM
system so at the end the kernel will
receive I think it's for sockets or
something like this there is one socket
where you can send the common that you
want you cannot to execute another
socket that is more for to send like
commands to control the kernel like when
you kill the colonel but you want to
stop this goes through this socket what
else then there is a third bit socket so
just to test it the kernel is life and
then another important to know how it
work is like the output socket so the
kernel will run and when the kernels
gets the the output from the standard
output or the standard error or some
extent exceptions it will broadcast that
output to to all the clients that are
listening to him to that kernel so that
is it the kernel it will broadcast and
someone has to take care of all these
and who is taking care about this this
output that is generating your kernel
know that is when you are running
yourself is there the notebook server
the notebook server it's like when you
run Jupiter not book it's like the web
service that you are starting what it
will do the this notebook server
it's forwarding this output to the to
the client that it's the browser and
will be the browser that it will put
this output in your cell in the notebook
that means that it's the browser itself
who is taking care of the status of the
state of your netbook notebook so when
you when you get so that means that the
kernel generates this broadcast this
output it goes forwarding through the
server and it gets your browser and then
you know that the notebook is
periodically saving storing your your
notebook that means that it goes again
from the
all this data that you have fun memory
on your browser it goes back to the
server and then it's the server that it
restores to the file so you you see
notice it's it's simple it's okay no so
then it's the normal flag the normal
thing how it works this iteration it's
all the time like this this is more an
overview of different more more detail
it with all the components more or less
it's like don't you have the kernel the
middle is the notebook server that is
the capital coeur-de-lion the env format
model is the one that fits take care to
store the notebook to a file then you
can have several clients on top of it
one it's the browser the notebook that
we know there is also the ND compare
that it's just converting the format
into HTML for example you notebook and
then from here the society's interesting
the day and the top little part it's
different options that you have when you
want to have a server that it will start
many notebooks to how to control all of
them for example this is Jupiter half
that I will explain a bit more in later
that is when you want to authenticate
the users then is that TMP and be this
one it's a it's like I think they wanted
is using my vendor dotnet my vine binder
or net that is that when used it will
start anonymously session no it will
start one jupiter notebook it will run
and when the session it closes it stops
the the notebook so it's like a
temporary not book where you can run one
and then the other one is some I haven't
use it it's for like do some kind of
more exams for student IDs so and the
last one maybe you also know it like
just everywhere so
we'll convert using the nd convert to
HTML and it will present you the
notebooks as a next email so this all
this is I want you to have this overview
of how all these things work because now
I I saw what what do I want when I want
to run for our users in for the people
in my lab when we want to use notebooks
in in our cluster so first I need an
entry point so that means that it's it's
a service that it will proxy the
requests so further it may have several
notebooks running so we want someone
that proxies the request to all the
other notebooks then we want to
authenticate the users we also want some
kind of central management we will like
to be able to share with other users our
notebooks the ones that are running for
a new ones even if to start on a
notebook that we have done we will like
this one that it's real-time
collaborative and not book editing so
that means for me this means like when
you are editing editing a Google Drive
document that you can see in real time
what are the other users doing this I
mean this like is like what I will like
now it's like obviously and that at the
last point I also want that my users can
start running something and then they
keep that running they can close their
laptops they browser whatever and they
can came back no and they have
everything they're running still running
without any problem this last point is
what I found that it was problematic and
I started to look for a solution it was
problematic why I don't know
you have experienced that but if you
start running a very long cell that it
will takes a lot of time and you are
interesting in getting the output but
because I didn't told you but our our
setup is that we are we are working
always with laptops and we go and
connect to our cluster so then we want
to be able to cause our browser or
laptop go home and then at night check
it no but with the long-running cells we
have the problem that because that thing
that I told you before that it's the
browser itself with keeping the status
of your document we were losing the the
cell output we this the process was
still running because it's running in
the kernel and we have can do some kind
of work around to check if the process
has finished but the thing is that we
it's not it's not quite easy it's not
straightforward and also that in our lab
we have not only computer science we
also have a logic positions from biology
a lot many backgrounds that they don't
want to care about these things they
want the things to work and as expected
and that's all the interesting thing is
that I was not alone because I thought
first ok there may be some kind of
solution to this because iPhone we want
to run the real and jobs in ourselves in
the notebook and in fact there are
several issues in the github for the
project Jupiter most of them are already
closed I found one that it's still open
No and they are like cross referencing
the thing is more if you have if you
have read the second part it's like Dex
it's like they say ok also they would
like to have this dis implemented but
it's I think that it's like some it's
complex in some way so if they say
it has been planned for edges to
implement this so it's something that at
some point it will works like the cows
will be the the notebooks that you built
our server who will be keeping the
status of the document or in some other
ways I don't know I also want to say
that I'm not a Java developer in fact I
have been only developing in Python last
three years something like this I'm not
really an actor but they they it's that
we are in this point so what was the
possible solution for observing students
this is like the good solution so if you
want to set up this like for example it
depends on the case but if you are doing
a workshop and you want your students to
be able to run Jupiter notebook then go
and use this it's like it will
authenticate your users it will start
the notebooks without any problem the
only problem is this thing that the
long-running jobs you will still have
this problem that you will have to if
you have our gas station and you start
your notebooks in your work station then
it's not that problem you keep the work
station working or the night and that's
it so then the solution that with the
type test no it was a combination using
docker strong cluster this is not
exclusive or the solution also with
Jupiter hub you can run the notebooks in
a swarm but the thing is that I did a
container an image of of docker that it
integrates a a remote desktop server
that is VNC server with the browser
itself and the Jupiter so it means that
the browser is running in next to the
Jupiter so it's keeping the status there
and then I use the welcome the Apache
Wacom Allah so it's like just a gateway
for for remote desktops I know I will
pass very quickly to some scripts so
some how it was implemented it's already
in this github repository I have done
like here you can emulate everything in
a built in a little box
so I just don't don't be don't worry
about the code because it just explain
how it work more or less I don't want to
go in big data and if you have any
question so first I don't know who has
an either I would like to know who has
an idea of what piece more or less and
docker okay me near everybody so that I
wasn't expecting to wind expert racks oh
ok so for the ones that you don't know
docker is just I will say like a suite
of tools I will say like it works it is
it helps you to work in a very friendly
way with containers this is docket and
then what is a container a container is
some way that you can run processes in a
very isolated way so that means that you
will be able to limit your process what
is the file system that they can see how
many memory they can use how many CPU
things like this so this is layer of the
Andorran containers photos of you didn't
know so then the cluster the swarm the
Sun is just the name of the how they
call in docker the cluster so for
example in this example that it's in the
scripts in the repository in the first
lines it's you will see it's very easy
to create an emulating IANA meter
installed little box and then dock your
machine and the first three lines you
you are creating like a cluster in your
rattle and the other part it applies
exactly the same if you are doing this
in a real cluster with real machines so
the fifth step is just need to
initialize the manager of the cluster
you can have more than one it works the
manager they cooperate with the
consensus protocol
and then for the rest of the north you
just need to do this swan join with the
token and the IP of the manager and
that's it you have the cluster so when
you run a new service or new container
in your cluster it can run anywhere in
the cluster and here it's more the
example how then I set up the things
first I create two virtual networks
inside the cluster one it's the proxy
network that is just because I always
want to map any service that I have to a
single URL so all of them to be able for
example if I have a set to services
running different containers part 18
I come up them to a two different URLs
so this is why I use this this network
and also you will see the first stack
here and the second network the notebook
sir Novak's is the one that I will
connect all the netbooks so they can
interact with the Apache Wacom all that
is the one who is going to serve the
desktop view of all of my Jupiter
containers unlike this I start at this
different stack a stack it like us a
group of services that the service is
like a container so it's a very simple
way to define a set of services that you
want to run I run the proxy run the
wacom all and I run the registry so here
is an example of this image this is how
in docker you can specify what do you
want to run inside the container this is
the main most interesting part of the of
this project
it's that how I create this image that I
start installing only the DNC server the
Firefox and you see here the time
installing Minicon de donde so that's
how I set up this
this image that it will be able to run
many containers and then I we have for
its user to be able to to customize
their own image if they need something
else or different or at least they I
don't want to run the container salute
and change the user ID so I have one
different image for each user this is
global because we are on it was so I
mean if you want to do this in a for
more users that's not the way to go
there are better solutions and this the
last step is just to set up the
configuration of that drumming container
to say to say what folders will be able
to run so normally this is pointing to
the project folder where where we have
our project with the coded ipython
notebooks itself and the Python scripts
also you can see because there is a
condensed out and then it's also
important to defined the path to the
Conda where it will have the environment
so then the user the end user can
install anything an environment inside
the this folder that it's a network file
system folder so we keep the
environments next to the project that's
the idea behind this then well for this
we have an automatic scrip to do these
two steps but just to clarify and you
need to configure the connection in
guacomole and then wacom all to get
something like this you can see that
you're running the knowledge that you
are running here with this project but
because it's it's a platform a web
platform version 4 and remote the stop
access you can have other things that's
like in these ways a bit more generic
solution for example we can have access
to a Windows no because we are working
with
and then but sometimes we still need to
go and do something with office this was
just illustrate that peeps you can do
other things and this is like how it
looked like with like a browser inside a
browser I was impressed that that is
working very well I was expecting more
delay and it's very it works very well
the this whack-a-mole project it's a
student incubator project in a patch but
it's really in really good I was
impressed about this even I compared
with some remote desktop clients that I
have installed in my machine and this
one that is going through through the
through the roster it's better then it
gives us another solution I mean this is
like a workaround because I would like
to be able to run themselves without any
problem directly in the gbj and also I
will like this real-time editing
capability and with this solution we
also get this in some way because a
batch of akamalik with you the option to
the option to to share your connection
your screen so it you can share in two
ways with full access or only read
access the full access it means that you
will send this link to the other two 200
you want to check to share with and it
will be able to connect and control also
the mouse and the keyboard so it can for
example help using something but the
thing is it's like it's real-time
because you can be in a hangout talking
or with the Skype and then the other can
also interact but it's like you have to
fight for the keyboard now it's only one
at a time it's like I walk it out here
peg sharing your notebook but it's
useful it use holy cows in our
we have different backgrounds and
they're useful sometimes to be able to
help anyone in the group that they told
me okay this is not working can you give
it a load or what is that just share me
the link and I will go there with no
problem I will see exactly the same in
fact I will see what I am doing so even
if we are not in the same office it's
it's very useful for for help or
interact with and with someone else in a
notebook so ok and what about pros and
cons of this setup as I told you it's a
workaround and there is the Jupiter hub
that it's a very good solution and I say
that you have to try you better have
it's also in many cases even better than
this maybe but this has some advantages
that it's like this one the main that we
want that you can disconnect at any time
so it's because we have the browser
inside the container and we are not
going to lose never the status this was
the the main reason we did that then
NASA collateral effect we get this kind
of concurrent not book editing we were
looking for that but it's also useful
and then another thing is that you you
have an entry point where you can have
anything not only Jupiter notebooks if
we need to have say one machine with
with Inkscape with a lot of memory we
can have there and the user to go to
exactly the same entry point and they
access our machine that has an ink scale
that needs a lot of memory and they can
use that that tool and with this I can
imagine many other situations cons
things that are not that I don't like
you know the copy and paste because of
the
that the browser itself it's not allowed
to share the great bar of the users so
it's like indirect from inside them the
container you have to copy it will
appear in our lateral box that you can
open and then from there you copy to
your host let scrolling that when you
work with the Jupiter it works perfectly
the only thing that you notice is when
you scroll when you scroll then you you
can see a bit of delay but still it's
it's quite useful it's not about then
the last one is not really a counted as
the look and feel it's a bit strange
sometimes because you have a browser
inside a browser and maybe the look and
feel of loss is different but you can
put in fullscreen the host browser and
then it looks like you were inside so
now I have three slides about the filter
this one is more about things that maybe
we can do to improve our solution but I
would like to add a graphical interface
to be able to instead of having a script
to create the notebooks to be more
graphical for this maybe I will have two
solutions one solution because Jupiter
hub can also run containers why not and
at the end Wacom Allah gives you a URL
where you can connect maybe it's
possible to integrate this inside
Jupiter hub just that the container that
it will start it will be quite different
and it will go with will go through the
Apache diamond as a Apache Wacom Allah
diamond another option will be the other
way Apache Wacom all it it's not for
remote - not only for remote desktop
it's very interesting for example they
also have a SSH protocol so you can also
add connections that are SSH connections
telnet connections why not it's possible
to implement like a proxy connection so
that the only thing that is doing its
proxying the HTTP and WebSockets to the
notebook then I
we have an autumn like it would be very
similar to what it's doing to be their
Hut but you also will have the option to
have this remote desktop protocol and
the last one that this one is very
simple it just to add on to be the lab
that does the same this one that's quite
interesting the real-time collaboration
it's coming in in Jupiter it's coming in
Jupiter lab they are working on it I
didn't test it it seems that there is
like a first implementation but they
will see is that this will be very soon
available it will be that they they plan
to do like fish that you you will have
used a Google Drive real-time API if you
are running in your laptop and you want
to synchronize to it to share your to
let someone to edit also in real-time or
we will also integrate it more
integrated in the Jupiter hub so this is
a good news that I think that we will
also use but it is still not not there
working progress and then another thing
that I think that it will be very nice
in the future even if we use Wacom all
do we have whatever but using running
the notebooks inside the controller
container is this checkpoint feature
that already has docker but in the
experimental when you run as
experimental the end engine the thing
this means is like some kind of figure
nation so so when you create the
checkpoint you are like a storing the
status of the memory of the container
and you are like stopping the container
and you can even move to another host
that container and restart there again
why I think it's very interesting for us
because we the the notebooks
our long-running jobs on time running
jobs so with the traditional cluster
that we have that we have both systems
that it's a cue system that you have an
a scheduler then the long-running jobs
are not working very very well because
you always have there and maybe at some
point you need like to remove the stop
but in this way we can let the user
start day notebooks there is no problem
if they have many but maybe we will say
ok you only you can only have three
running at a time the other ones we are
going to burn aid your notebooks or we
are in a hurry and we need more
computation for some other thing we are
going we are very sorry but we hang work
beside that notebooks of some user and
we are going to give priority to someone
else or for example this notebook is
running out of memory but we have been
running for one week what we can do now
what we can do we can do it implemented
better or even ate that container and
start it in another house with more
memory
maybe because we are research group and
we only want to run many times I think
only once
maybe will with these works we will do
this second option this is why I wanted
to share with you this thing that it's I
think it's coming and it's very near and
will be very interesting so thank you
you want to add something to this vision
or questions or whatever it will be very
interesting so thank you so any
questions yeah
thank you for the presentation it's very
interesting I actually used to be a hub
and had the same problem Israel for
example for real time and collaborative
clever collaborator essay editing the
question I have and you partially
answered it with the information is that
normally when you have a docker
container running Easter's for small
process that sells itself at the end of
the actual action right so your I get
the point that your browser is in the
docker file but the the image itself so
it doesn't kill itself when you log off
but still it means that it keeps running
as an image at some point so that's the
first question is it really the core of
docker in the first engine instance and
regarding the data you use in your
notebooks how do you package it is it in
the in the image is it that heavy or do
you use volumes that you linked with the
image W
it's about yes it's this container
running three processes this is not the
what they want mean in docker
they say docker has to run only it's the
perfect phylosophy the perfect way but I
think that near nobody is doing this
maybe because logger is more for make
micro services we are starting to use
very many different ways so yes I'm
running three processes four processes
in one container one is the Firefox the
remote server and what is abuser itself
and the other one is the supervisor that
is the one that starts all the other
three processes that's not a problem
okay you are losing some CBOE but it's
not a problem it's stable and it's
distributes very low and that's another
good thing because sometimes you crash
your laptop
due to this or yours with all impatient
you started printing in your cell I like
1 1 million off rows and then it guys
your know maybe you will crash if it
happens it will crash the container or
it will it will be more because we can
leave me put the image to the container
that also interesting maybe at the end
will be a dog hair that will kill or
will be a less priority to your
container because is using a lot of CPU
and the second we we have we have in our
host servers with natural filesystem
double the different volumes that we
want and we share this into the we share
ask your volumes into but but not
mounting using network file system it
just in the normal I think when you are
doing in your laptop like from the file
system hi thanks for the talk
so if I understand correctly you're
running a virtual machine where you run
a browsers so that you can that browser
can keep the notebook state I'm not I
don't know how that state is represented
maybe some cookies maybe more I don't
know
have you considered sewing to to have
this on your browser and not on a
virtual browsers through here VNC
have you considered like a headless
browser that would keep your state and
then maybe a method to move that state
if it's just cookies it is not that it's
hard to your browser so that you can
just take over the state and run it on
your browser well that this state is
more like in memory I will say like in
the HTML 3 knowledge ok yeah man so if
you if you close the tab on your it does
it does the computation stop yeah yeah
it's the same case closing the tab
how soon is not and the other thing is
that it's not very
is naughty night like daughter it's not
nothing is beautiful it's not a real all
my senior yeah yeah I know process but
with some restrictions no no I was I was
talking about the BNC thing which it
looks a bit numbers you also a bit of
overhead because you also need to yeah
so I was wondering if you could just run
it through something like phantom gears
which is a headless browser browser that
but yes but I guess that the overhead
will be the same and then I still you
need some kind
I guess that the setup is quite more
complex I cannot imagine I don't know
but but technically a headless browser
it will keep the status maybe you I
don't know I was I was also trying
without the remote desktop like directly
using the X Windows but then it's less
when you are in a cluster this is more
dangerous maybe for your laptop it's
perfect you can run graphical interfaces
inside a container just mapping the X
akkad but but in a cluster it's it's a
bit dangerous and less possible I have
one question
melodic question but you have experience
ruining Jupiter have I which is smile
I test it my experience is testing
Jupiter have more than okay now my
question was about the performance of
Jupiter happen compared with Jupiter on
local moon I don't know if you have any
benchmarks I don't have the mobile at
the end it's like it's just a proxy and
Jupiter half is just forwarding your
request to to the your your Jupiter
server the Jupiter not do that you have
so I mean that the the what you lose is
very very insignificant not like in my
solution that you you lose some
performance because you are you are
doing the remote desktop that you have
to share all the screen so in Jupiter
have this
like I will say if you have everything
properly set up in your main server and
everything well dimension it's like if
you are directly running to you are
going to be likely connecting to the
Jupiter notebook
thanks more questions
and once you start running the process
are they also demanding some sort of
other system that tells them okay your
process has finished and they get
notified report process that take today
to run I'm a you are eager to see the
results or the team is eager to see the
results and they say it's ready
no the answer is no and if I do that it
will like more a magic in the cell some
kind of math maybe it's already done I
don't know if someone knows that I
imagine them that you put a magic no
that send me amazed make no undersell
and at the end it was engineered but I
don't know if if I had to implement this
I will doing that way that they want
testing that we have that we are
monitoring our cluster and we are so
recollecting the locks of our cluster
but it is small I can a system admin
level no not for the user is any other
question okay so this is a an applause
for Jordi thank you George
[Applause]